what's going on guys this is rob and
tomorrow's what if episode at least the
time that i'm recording this basically
focuses on black panther if he became
star-lord and so i thought it'd be kind
of cool to do a video on the new powers
that t'challa has now more recently this
has changed as t'challa's gone back to
being black panther and ironically
enough we never covered this story at
least if we did i can't find it on the
channel anywhere so uh i don't imagine
that we've covered it but this is
basically where black panther becomes
the king of the dead now i thought about
titling at that but for obvious reasons
it seems kind of inappropriate after
chadwick boston's passing to call it
black panther becomes the king of the
dead just seems a little tasteless but
uh but nonetheless this is a really
really important story and it's actually
one that a lot of people are curious
about and and technically it comes off
the heels of and kind of an interim
comic but it comes off the heels of
jonathan hickman's fantastic four run
black panther himself doesn't really
have any direct involvement in the
fantastic four run of jonathan hickman i
mean he appears a little bit it's really
one of these stories where it kind of
segways into avengers and new avengers
by jonathan hickman as well as avengers
vs x-men but specifically it comes out
of the story of doom war now do-more was
a really cool story that i know we
covered
and it's basically where doctor doom
orchestrates a coup d'etat in wakanda
which basically sees black panther and
his sister shuri as well as t'challa's
wife's storm basically ousted as the
leaders of wakanda and this kind of
hyper-nationalist movement takes over
but the whole thing was designed to be a
ruse so dr doom could sneak into wakanda
steal all the vibranium which amplifies
magical energy and then make himself god
which successfully he did right he
managed to actually do that and then at
the end of the story black panther
basically had to eliminate or render all
the vibranium across the world
completely inert and so vibranium on
earth just basically became useless
chunks of rock and so that's really
where all this picks up but because of
the fact that t'challa had been injured
he passed the mantle onto his sister
shuri who became the new black panther
so that's kind of how you segue into
this but ultimately uh the fantastic
four are brought into wakanda by
t'challa himself right they're invited
here and there's a couple reasons for
this one of which we'll find out later
on over the course of the story but the
second one is because they're
long-standing friends right technically
in terms of publication history black
panther originally appeared in the
fantastic four stories but the fantastic
four were the first real group that
t'challa actually invited into wakanda
which was unheard of and in fact reed
didn't really know anything about
wakanda when he was invited there when
he showed up the technological
advancement of wakanda was mind-boggling
right they had achieved incredible
things with regards to all the stuff
they'd done i mean you guys saw that in
the black panther movie that there are
some pretty seedy things going on under
wakanda itself right and we'll kind of
get to those as we cross through it in
terms of the encounter and the reason
why reed is here the question that that
black panther asks is reid starts
talking about everything in the
aftermath of do-more the vibranium being
rendered inert that he and the future
foundation which is really more of a
think tank that's composed of younger
kids a little bit of an aside here
that's one of the things that you'll
probably see in the marvel cinematic
universe if ever there's an indication
that the fantastic four are officially
coming in the uh into the mcu what
you'll likely see is that peter parker
has been invited to join the future
foundation which is basically an
organization created by reed richards to
focus on like future projects different
things like that right it's a big think
tank but um but but the the whole
discussion here is that the future
foundation has been working on ways by
which wakanda can kind of re-establish
itself as a global power right because
without vibranium essentially they seem
to be worthless right they have no real
money they have nothing to really barter
for i mean to give the guys perspective
here vibranium was so was was worth so
much money a gram of vibranium would
sell for ten thousand dollars that's an
insane amount of money and when you're
sitting on a mountain of vibranium ima i
mean the the amount of money you have
would be countless right i mean it'd be
in the trillions of dollars but what
actually ended up happening here and
this is kind of a funny thing it's
really of a testament to the forward
thinking of black panther is that in the
idea that ultimately the vibranium they
had would either be taken from them or
they would kind of run through it or
whatever the case was that the idea was
to basically diversify and so what
t'challa had been doing was actually
going through and liquidating a lot of
the vibranium and then selling it off
for huge amounts of money which they
basically invested in and diversified
the other thing that they had done is
they had bought up the national debt or
huge chunks of the us us government's
national debt so in effect the u.s
government would be paying wakanda for
seemingly forever right because you know
it's just national debt
but basically the overall gist of this
is that wakanda's not going broke
anytime soon right wakanda you know
their their value stands in the
trillions of dollars and so while
they're not necessarily worth as much as
they were before they have more cash on
hand than they did before and so it's
it's still beneficial to them in a
variety of ways now what's also kind of
going on behind the scenes here is that
at some point in the distant past and
this is kind of interesting the panther
god bast had dealings with the egyptians
now technically the panther god bast is
actually an egyptian god which is
something that a lot of people don't
know but best following the i guess
formation of wakanda had gained the
attention of the wakandans themselves
but the biggest question that was always
asked is how how did bass go from being
a egyptian god to becoming the goddess
of the wakandans and the reason why was
because during a point in the history of
earth especially when it came to the
egyptian gods themselves in marvel
comics gods do wage war against one
another specifically anubis had killed
almond rock and then taken the heart of
amun ra and then intended to use this in
order to bring a kind of endless knight
to basically control all those who were
dead bast had essentially intervened and
taken the heart of amonroth for herself
and then in turn buried it in wakanda as
far away or a pretty good amount away
from uh from egypt now big question kind
of asked here i have to ask you is why
not just bury it in the new world or
someplace like that we don't really get
an answer to that instead it was just in
the very early days of wakanda this is
the reason why or at least one of the
reasons why the black panthers were
created is because over time the black
panthers themselves served as served as
much protectors of the great mound of
vibranium and building a kingdom around
it in order to kind of you know expand
their wealth as they were keeping
anybody from getting the heart of amon
roth and then hanni or at least anubis
himself grabbing it and then kind of
taking over as an endless knight and so
as a result what you basically have
going on in kind of the background here
is anubis basically returning
resurrecting forces constantly trying to
take this heart from from wakanda and
then that's basically it it's not the
most important thing but it is a bit of
an important thing because of course at
the moment shuri is the current black
panther and in the middle of dinner with
the fantastic four the wakandans and all
that kind of stuff that you have the
forces of almond raw that basically
launch an invasion and uh try to break
in and try to steal the heart by taking
out the black panther and basically the
earthly avatar of bast and so on and so
forth now the reason why that kind of
matters here is that while these forces
are defeated that t'challa takes reed
richards and they basically leave
together but they're going on a kind of
journey of sorts to a really cool
destination and of course reed is
basically wished farewell by the dora
malachi as well as susan storm but
there's a big concern that reed may not
be the person that t'challa needs in the
face of what they're going to basically
end up coming across and so for the
first time in the history of marvel
comics you're introduced to this amazing
concept and one of the big questions
that was asked up until this point is
that if t'challa is the current black
panther following his father t'chaka and
then the various black panthers that
came before him where do they go when
they die and so ultimately this
basically reveals to us a place called
the necropolis and the necropolis is
very much a holy city among wakandans
right it is a it's a place where only
really black panthers can go um no one
else is really allowed there it's a very
ceremonial and a very holy place more so
than that it's been around for an
exceedingly long time and so as reed
richards and t'challa enter into this
place what you also have is kind of like
this this gorgeous display of all these
old hieroglyphics and all these old
signs that predate most of the early
empires on earth now this is a bit of a
timeline and continuity issue when it
comes to marvel because wakanda as it
currently exists has only been around
for about 10 000 years right in the
sense that the first wakandan became the
first black panther and so on and so
forth uh what this seems to be the case
of is that largely it was most likely a
scenario where people in this part of
the world where they would bury their
debt right that's kind of how we use or
use that that line as a kind of standard
between primitive and and really
disorganized societies versus organized
societies right the burying of their
debt that life essentially matters it
may have been one of these things that
as time progressed the necropolis was
transformed from this place where just
the dead were buried to a holy city
where those individuals who served as
black panther would go on to be buried
and as much of a tribute to bass as it
is anything else and so you kind of have
two things that go on at the same time
the first is that the the kind of
spiritual journey that's undertaken by
black panther and reid is also not
really met but you also have a spiritual
journey of sorts that's being being
taken by shuri susan storm and storm
herself because the idea is that they're
actually gonna go into the afterlife and
they're basically gonna face off against
anubis and then essentially defeat him
right they're gonna you know basically
destroy anubis and honestly that's
really all that happens there for black
panther himself as far as the new powers
go he and reed basically enter into a
kind of temple in the uh necropolis
itself to be met by the arrival of the
panther god bass now one of the things
to know bast does not just stay here all
the time right that bass kind of comes
and goes as as he or she is needed when
it comes to these different gods in
marvel comics with somebody like bass
bass was technically a male god in the
egyptians and then a female god as far
as the the wakandans go but it's used
interchangeably right bass doesn't
really have a particular form it's not
really a guy or a girl it just kind of
shifts based on the circumstance and
that's why you hear scenarios even among
the wakandans themselves well they'll
refer to bass is both a god and a
goddess because when you're on that
level i guess it doesn't really matter
what you ascribe to but the important
thing is that uh you end up having
basically bass kind of bringing rid reed
richards towards her and then saying
what's your role here and ultimately
because of the fact that reed and
t'challa have really been teammates and
fought together for so long that they're
really they really kind of see each
other as brothers right now a lot of
that is a respect that came by way of
just surviving conflicts together
fighting together but also their
intelligence right one thing to know is
that when it comes to intelligent
characters of marvel comics it's not
really a direct hierarchy it kind of is
but it kind of isn't that if you look at
somebody like tony stark tony stark's
very smart but tony stark's a futurist
and that's why a lot of the technology
he builds is ahead of what a lot of
other people have done but reed richards
could build an iron man suit that's not
outside his his realm of possibility the
biggest problem with reed richards is
he's always trying to solve the problem
of everything that was one of the things
that was kind of laid out during
jonathan hickman's fantastic four but
then you have somebody like black
panther who's highly intelligent but not
necessarily on the same level as reid so
it's just one of these weird little
little wonky things so you can make a
hierarchy if you want to and i'm sure
they exist out there but as far as this
element goes between t'challa and reed
their intelligence because of the fact
that they fought wars alongside each
other against various threats there's a
lot of respect there right that and the
fact that reid always honored what it
was that t'challa was trying to do at
almost any point in time and pretty much
always sided with him and that's what he
says here right i am a loyal second i'm
here out of loyalty because t'challa
trusts me and we trust each other like
brothers and so when he's brought before
bass he basically kind of stands there
to observe everything and the question
that's asked by by bass among black
panther is why are you here tell me
what's in your heart now this is
important this is not a question it's
really almost kind of a challenge of
sorts right it's not as though bass does
not know what black panther wants if
black panther lies they'll be hell to
pay and so it's basically one of these
things where it's like tell me what's in
your heart tell me what you really want
i.e if you give me any answer other than
what i already know i'll probably kill
you and so the response of t'challa is i
want to be what i was before i want to
be a king right i want to be the black
panther and the question that that bass
asks is then what do i do with your
sister because your sister is currently
the black panther you pass that mantle
on to her when you sustained an injury
during doom war and that if i make you
the black panther that takes that power
away from her and right now she's in the
afterlife fighting anubis if i remove
her from being the black panther she
will die you will basically cost your
sister her life not only that it'll be
an ultimate betrayal among your own
people because they will see the mantle
it passed on and then you took it back
and it doesn't work that way when the
mantle is passed on willingly to the
next person it stays with that person
until such a time as that person dies
and you retake the mantle for yourself
or if that person loses the loses any
kind of worth as a black panther they
betray wakanda or something like that
but their actions are deemed so
dishonorable they're not worthy of being
black panther anymore and then the manta
would pass back to you again and so
ultimately the response of t'challa is
like i love my sister and i love the the
people who are with her i can't possibly
be asked to make such a choice you
cannot ask this of me and the responsive
vast is i can and i will right bass says
it's your desires that are being judged
here i chose you in the womb most
favored son you are mine as much as any
other so if it is in your heart's desire
to be the champion of your people i will
make you the panther again you want to
rule then sit on the golden throne be a
boy king i give it to you but i have
greater needs if you are still fit and
still a man to be feared and that takes
t'challa by surprise because usually
bass doesn't come along and say i have
need of you right it's usually he's the
black panther there's a black panther
that comes after him and they fight in
the glory or in the service of bass
right at the pleasure of best in order
to keep wakanda safe from whatever
threats may come and ultimately the
response of bast is see it with your own
eyes right and basically shows t'challa
what it is you know the kind of future
that's coming and this leads into a
bunch of different things right avengers
versus x-men when the phoenix force
returns and then all hell breaks loose
among the superhero community the fact
that the necropolis and wakanda are
going to be flooded by name of the
submariner which basically brings in the
giant blood feud between neymar the
submariner and the atlanteans and black
panther and wakandans right for those of
you guys who are always curious why it
is that name of the submariner and black
panther hate each other so much it's
because name of the submariner flooded
wakanda killed a ton of people and that
black panther responded by killing a ton
of atlanteans right so they were they
were basically at war with each other
even through jonathan hickman's avengers
the new avengers run but given the fact
that the multiverse was collapsing it
was pretty much a ceasefire but what she
says is like this is what awaits right
the phoenix force is returning all
hell's going to break loose in wakanda
and the golden city will fall and that
pales in comparison to what follows
right basically the incursions is what
bass is referencing the collapse of the
multiverse and so she says you ask what
greater need is there than service the
answer to that is salvation so i ask you
again t'challa what do you desire to sit
on the throne or to save your people i.e
your sister shuri is not going to be the
person who's going to save your people
and so of course when when t'challa says
i will be whatever it is that you need
me to be then this just solidifies
things right so of course bass shows
that kills anubis that's basically it
right kind of manifests a version of
herself out there that takes out anubis
right because anubis is always trying to
rise to power whatever anyway uh the the
end result is that bass is in necropolis
the wakandan city of the dead where all
black panthers go to die this is where
you will rule as the king of the dead
now this was hugely important because if
you guys saw the black panther film a
few years ago one of the things that you
saw of course was that t'challa could
communicate with former black panthers
that was not originally a power he had
that was not something that he was
always able to do as black panther
that's something that came out of this
this is this is something that's brand
new the fact that he can communicate
with previous black panthers he has
their wisdom their knowledge the battles
that they faced off against right they
can all impart that directly to him and
he can in turn use that for his own ends
but he also sits at the judgment of
these other black panthers while they
can't necessarily stand in and strip him
of his mantle they can basically say
you've betrayed everything that we stand
for and while that may not seem
important to a person like t'challa who
sees himself as an honorable man and
who's whose role as a black panther is
really designed to ensure that he
maintains the honor of not just wakanda
but all the black panthers that came
before him but ultimately because of
what's going on here that t'challa is
quote unquote returned to the role of
black panther but not really right the
role of black panther among the wakandan
people right their leader their king
that still resides with shuri the
important thing about this though is
that when it all hits the fan that it's
all going to come down to t'challa that
he is a black panther it's like almost
kind of a personal black panther for
bass but more so than that he's the king
of the dead that's how it is he's able
to control marvel zombies during the
events of the secret wars event in 2015.
but i thought this would be a cool story
to cover and i thought it'd be
interesting right how it is that
t'challa gained his new powers and
basically became king of the dead in
marvel comics but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace